[Music]
it was deeply shocking and I worked with
them Laurene it's sweet it's
embarrassing I'm really fast we're part
of it how many times are you going to
ask you the same question thank you
[Music]
the terrible fire at not radar saw
hundreds of years of history
disintegrates in minutes I was among the
crowds gathering and looking on as the
glaze began to take hold
we tried to capture the emotions of
France as a birthing that embodies its
spirits like no other looked close to
being lost that night is the start of a
week of deep sound reflections but also
a determination to rebuild
as I watched last night along with
people all over the world and certainly
the people on the streets of Paris it
was deeply shocking and I went with them
because a cathedrals such as Notre Dame
expresses so much of what's in the human
heart what's in our hearts you know I
thought as you saw the streets lined
with people who were in shock silence
for the most part some were tears and
then every now and then there were
groups of people who were praying and
singing even as their Cathedral burned
and I thought it is fascinating it shows
the relationship between the communities
of faith and what is generally a secular
society that somehow those who found
words and sang were expressing what was
in the hearts of everybody else and
that's what a cathedral does it it
expresses the deepest longings of the
human heart and that's why it will be
rebuilt I'm sure and since the the Great
Gothic cathedrals in this country have
gone to the Church of England I suppose
it is the sort of nearest historic
monument almost other than the urlan
dreams perhaps I think such is the
relationship between the churches now
that we don't have that sense of
alienation between us and you know the
responsibility for medieval buildings is
very heavy I've celebrated Mass and
Lichfield Cathedral you know I'm quite
often in Westminster Abbey I don't think
these are shared Heritage's now and I
know if you know if god forbid there was
a great tragedy in Westminster Cathedral
the abbey would be right there to help
us join up on the historical author Ken
Follett Ken thanks for joining us this
morning it feels here's a slightly
better mood in Paris because we still
have those towers behind me we still
have the stone structure of the building
but we think we've lost a lot as well I
was very heartened this morning when I
woke up and turned the TV on and
discovered that much more remained than
I had spent expected when I finally went
to bed last night I really thought I was
going to wake up in the morning
and see and see a flat landscape on the
Ile de la Cite a but it's marvelous that
the two square towers at the West End
are there my favorite view are not
redundant peri is from the east where
you see those wonderful flying
buttresses looks like a flight of birds
just taking off and that seems to be
intact apart from the roof itself the
flying buttresses are there and some
walls are there even some of the
vaulting appears to have survived the
curved ceiling inside the Cathedral
which is part of what makes it so
beautiful even some of that it has
survived and and that's very encouraging
and then of course on top of that these
relics and these artworks that that
French Catholics have have preserved and
have treasured for hundreds of years
many of these were actually rescued by
by pretty gutsy firemen who actually
went in there and and took them out so
the picture now is not quite as dismal
as it felt last night when I went to bed
and the genius building isn't just that
it's religiously important it's not just
that it's sacred and architecture and
put it it also holds a special place in
French culture doesn't it you're a
writer it's very important in French
literature as well as well as to Disney
as well and and filmmakers absolutely it
is that these churches have fired the
imaginations of writers and storytellers
for hundreds of years and the most
famous of course is Victor Hugo not too
damned aperi which in English is called
The Hunchback of Nitra Dom famous novel
by Victor Hugo the the Victor Hugo the
Charles Dickens of France and also had
been filmed several times and a
wonderful story but the other thing to
remember about this is that these
buildings connect us without past we
walk we walk past you know in England or
France most people live near medieval
buildings and we walk past them and we
can think that was built by my ancestors
hundreds of years ago and that links
me too my past and I think that's why
these buildings have such a place in our
hearts and I think it's why last night
you saw people standing in the streets
looking at this fire and just weeping
because they were losing something very
precious to me
almost 300 climate change activists have
been arrested in a second day of
protests in central London the tactics
of defiance and direct action are aimed
at getting maximum publicity for their
cause the point of it is to keep this
Laurie here if we keep the Laurie here
then we keep the road and if we keep the
road and because there's a sir up ssin
that we need to create none of us really
want to be creating disruption but we're
being forced to do that because we've
been completely ignored for the past
thirty years on what is now the most
unprecedented Lee broad and deep
emergency crisis that humans have ever
seen and where we're basically
committing suicide by not approaching it
with a sensible management head so
that's what we want to see from our
government and we're losing the
government to come to the table and
that's about and I'd love to be able to
do that with petitions and I'd love to
be able to do that with a March but
unfortunately those hasn't worked so
here I am locked to a lorry for ten
hours this first time I've done this so
it was really cause we're in the middle
of utterly red sea as you can imagine
the winds again it was going fast but
everyone's been really kind and they've
given us lots of food and drink and
blankets and things and it's also a bit
emotionally scary because you know that
you might get arrested and what you
don't know what that's going to be like
necessarily but overall there's a lot of
support here and I'd just hope that
people understand that we're doing this
for everyone and it's not just for us
it's not about trying to get attention
I really want to be here we're doing it
for everyone security you could say one
thing to the Prime Minister at present
climate I'd say please wake up please
take heed of the scientific consensus
and also trust your citizens I feel like
there's a complete lack of trust that if
we were to tell the truth about this
situation that people would just run
around like headless chickens that we'd
want to be and we would be able to
collective eyes to come together in a
sort of World War 2 style response and
really approach there sensibly and do
something really absolutely magnificent
about it see what we can get done if you
want to shut down the airport I don't
want to be the last generation oh I've
told you I'm here out of love and out of
fear and from that from that comes
courage and do you hope to shut down the
airport today
[Music]
my next guest was homeless as a teenager
but she is now one of the most senior
female firefighters in the UK she's dr.
Sabrina Cohen Hatton she's the Deputy
Assistant Commissioner for the London
Fire Brigade and she's just been
appointed the big issue magazines new
Sabrina good morning to you very well
especially after reading your story
because this is incredible you spent two
years as a teenager living on the street
and well let's start at the beginning it
was the big issue that you now find
yourself the ambassador of that gave you
the the encouragement and the means to
get back on your feet yeah absolutely I
mean it was a really difficult period of
my life I found myself homeless at 15
years old incredibly vulnerable and it
was a really difficult time to come out
of and the reason I did this it came
about actually because I wrote a book
called the heat of the moment and what I
wanted to do is say to other people who
were still in the same position now as I
was back when I was 15 years old that
actually your circumstances don't define
you you know they don't have to
determine where you end up just where
you start from it's interesting isn't it
because you know the biggest you gave
you a platform it gave you structure
it's a social enterprise to get you on
your feet to be able to join the fire
brigade at the age of 18 and what you've
gone on to do you've now got a doctorate
doctorate in psychology you mentioned
the book that you're writing there
you're high up in the London Fire
Brigade just you know in terms of giving
back and being this embassy ambassador
of the big issue what is it you want to
tell people now because you talked about
how for years you didn't want to mention
the fact that you were on the streets no
I hid it I completely hid it and in a
way I think this process writing the
book being involved with the big issue
has helped me to come to terms with who
I am and my own history in many respects
but as I said there are so so many
people out there in the same position
now that I was back then it's so
important for me to be able to reach out
to them and say that things can be
different you know and I mean the great
thing about the fire service is it took
what initially on paper didn't seem like
a fantastic prospect I mean I was a
young girl whose CV read NFA and whose
greatest
was making biggest event of the week but
they still passed that and they took me
on the strength of who they believed uh
kaboom
I know when Jared watson launched you
Kipps EU election campaign earlier this
week he was keen to point out why voters
should back you Kip instead of Nigel
Farage's new brexit party but there was
one issue that he wasn't very keen to
talk about and that was the controversy
surrounding one of his candidates
comments about rape on Twitter on the
rape joke you said it was a satirical
comment what did you mean by that well
that's the governor asked ol Benjamin
this is a three year old tweet that he
did in the context of some Twitter
trolling than what people were doing I'm
not asking about the comments he made
I'm asking about your defense of his
comments because he remains a you keep
candidate and you party and you have
made a decision to kill considered
remark and if you were going to stop
people taking part in public life or
anything else because of some stupid
ill-considered remark of several years
before then I don't think you'd have
anybody in Parliament or anywhere else
in public life because we all do things
which were we were regret he can defend
it or not as he likes but I'm not going
to stop having a valuable candidate on
the list someone who can get us access
to social media and thousands more
people that we can talk to that we can't
do through social media where few and
few people re less and less people are
actually listening to it or taking
notice of it so we're seeking other
avenues to the public that kind of
comment though has prompted some
concerns without question how many times
are you going to ask me the same
question thank you very much
[Music]
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange spent
seven years at the Ecuadorian Embassy in
London before he was evicted I've been
talking to a former diplomat who was
based there for six at those seven years
he's described Julian Assange as final
year at the Embassy as like hell witness
when Julian was told that he won't be
able to have internet he won't be able
to have access to telephone and he won't
be able to have visitors for me that's a
very very serious violation of his
rights during seven to eight months
Julian Assange was completely isolated
and communicated the only people who
were allowed to visit him were basically
his lawyers and his legal team and
people who bring him food a couple of
few exceptions I think that's absolutely
unacceptable why because the strategy
was very clear break him down Ecuador
has handed over a political refugee
persecuted for political reasons handed
over to the persecutors it had opened
its embassy to a foreign force to come
and basically kidnap a politically so
it's obviously they will they will try
to put the attention on smear
allegations just be clear on this you
say that during your six years at all
times Julian Assange with clean tidy and
respectful respectful hundred percent
clear and tidy
what is clean and tidy doesn't put the
dishes in the dishwasher
probably nor the weekends is that a
crime
I don't think so certainly is not excuse
to end up a political asylum is frankly
ridiculous don't you think Julian
Assange should face the music that he
should go to Sweden to face those rape
and molestation accusations and he
should go to the United States to face
any accusations that are against him
that he breached national security I
don't think she should go to the United
States in any case in any case yeah yeah
we became friends I support him I think
he's being feminist I feel ashame of my
government for demin Ising him but
smearing him
this morning it is of course fantasy
series as I said the show stars
with me now is the actress general
wheelers we plays we are a Greyjoy and
that congratulations you got to the last
season I made it yes
so far so good you you could always get
bumped off exactly yeah exactly I no
one's safe
I suppose you're in with the Cho's in
with a chance at least you know in with
a chance I'm there at least now you you
a quite ski not scary here but you're
quite sure
you're quite scary in the show you're
quite tough when it's tough in your
brother yes yes I am yeah I I enjoy
playing her because it's just a lot of
my own qualities just with the volume
turned up a bit I don't murder people
obviously and what does it involve for
you being in the series mean you get the
main quite cold place yeah again the
cold bits everyone goes off to Croatia
and even Iceland is on my bucket list
but them nan and s Belfast is fantastic
but it's often quite rainy and often the
scenes that look incredible with Alfie
and I on the ship with in a car park
with a green screen and they release the
way it looks when you know there's no
water unless they're spraying it and
throwing at you yeah because the
Greyjoy's are kind of a wait suppose you
can see a lot of water oh yeah we do go
up to the Antrim coast to the to the
ocean and we film there as well but if
we're on the ship when we're in a car
parking ban and toy and and you bet it's
over
no I'm not I'm neither glad nor sad I
just feel like it's right and I feel how
wonderful to sort of have ended in such
a bang of jewelry really it would be
terrible if it was a sort of you know if
it fizzled out I think it's really
exciting everyone's so behind it and so
thrilled to see that Iceland do you
follow the story because yeah you just
you know it's very episodic you're just
in a bit i watch it is a fan so I don't
like to hear anything of anyone else's
storylines and I only read the bits that
were relevant to me and then I can watch
it as a
I watched the first episode of live in
Belfast it's just
so it's incredible it's incredible
really proud to be part of it with yet
another Spring Royal baby on the way all
of the attention at the moment is on the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex this week
I've been taking a look at some of the
online abuse as being targeted at Megan
so I caught up with Princess Tessie of
Luxembourg who talked to me about what
it's like marrying into a monarchy what
the scrutiny my family suffered greatly
when I married into the family my little
cousin she needed to change school twice
my twin brother was incredibly bullied
at work still is today
my sister my parents suffer hits my
oldest brother doesn't talk to me
anymore because of that because it was
too much for him to handle and that was
when I married him and then when I got
divorced so my gosh the same it's just
you know what I have learned is you can
never please everyone and some people
will just like to talk bad about you but
you know it's it's about choosing your
battles and that's why when I saw for
example the whole negative media
attention to the towards Dodgers I
thought no one should be treated like
that
you know it's it's you know I don't know
her personally to be honest I know
Prince Harry really well he's a very
nice guy and I can imagine marrying her
she must be wonderful too but taking
that away of who she is no person man a
woman should be witch-hunt really like
to head of online I know what it is I
had it I have it
and I probably will have it in the
future as well and I think why I did it
and why I stand up for her and for a lot
of other people as well is because my
children read these things and I don't
want my children to grow up in such an
environment this is not the society I
want my kids to grow up in it's it's
it's really it's embarrassing it's
really embarrassing to see that human
beings can be like that with each other
against each other often towards people
that they don't even know and I think
you know a screen
should not give you the protection and
the right to say what you want
I'm all for freedom of speech it's great
and it's needed however one should not
confuse freedom of speech with how they
from time to time write about people
there is a line and some people cross
that line and that's not OK when you're
in the public eye you have a
responsibility
so yes you do when I stress this some
time to time and you have nice events
and so on but also it brings yet as I
said to brings responsibility people
look up to you like little girls for
example you know I I have often when
little girls see me and they say you are
your real princess and they're their
eyes are shiny and they are just in
heaven really that that moment is so
precious to them and I think as such you
know you really realize I have I need to
make sure that that young girl grows up
in in the society that she deserves